hi Matt Welch here co-author with nick
gillespie of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America this
is our last of the ask of libertarian
day we've had a great time thank you
very much to everybody for sending these
thoughtful and challenging questions
we've certainly learned a lot in the
process about each other really things
but I'm going to take the co-authors or
/ moderators prerogative and ask a last
question of my own that gets into some
of the stuff that we talk about in the
book which is Nick you're sort of the
author or the popularizer of the notion
of libertarianism being more of an
adjective than a noun a pre political
impulse walk us through just a little
bit of what you mean by that and how
that might play out in our near-term
future in American politics yeah I mean
I think it's useful not to think about
libertarian as a you know a set I set of
ideas or a set set of programs and
policies but it is an adjective it's a
it's a descriptor it's an impulse
towards bringing more freedom more
options to people more choices in any
given situation it's a default setting
that can be overridden at times I think
it's on the grow that's why independence
as a group or growing it it's more
importantly it's why the Democrats and
Republicans liberals and conservatives
who for whatever differences they might
have they want to limit choices to the
small menu that they say are good
libertarians go in a different direction
and we've been living in a libertarian
world for some time now in all of the
areas of our lives that matter most to
us away from the government so when you
get outside of education when you get
outside of health care and entitlements
you've got more choices than you ever
had before whether it's the way you live
the way you look or what you buy and you
know so that I think is going to carry
over into the political arena and it
should Matt my question for you has to
do with the question of you know why now
is it is it really what we've called the
libertarian moment why why is it
different this time around three reasons
one is that I don't think in our
lifetimes there's been a bigger gap
between what the American public are
obviously expressing what they want
politically to happen and what their
elected leaders are actually doing I
mean we've had consistent messages
basically since the inaction of tarp in
the fall of 2008 it's been wildly
unpopular bailout economics is wildly
unpopular in addition to being wildly
ineffective made wildly bipartisan
wildly bipartisan and yet you know we've
had tea party movement we have we've had
so much data on this and it hasn't
reached the ears of politicians so that
gap is wide and yet at the same time
it's never been easier for individual
citizens to swarm together impacts about
single issues and affect the way things
are because the third reason Democrats
and Republicans have less market share
their there there's their web over our
brains is less the magic spell is being
broken and so all this is combining to
make us understand you know the great
stuff that we can do in our private
lives we're beginning to be able to
inflict it on the Winnebago of state
well Matt it's been a pleasure working
with you obviously for years now but
writing the Declaration of Independence
which is for sale now online and in
meatspace as well thank you very much
thank you Nick and thanks to everybody
for watching and also sending in your
questions we only got to a very small
fraction but it was a hell of a lot of
fun